Ngài Habeva thương mấy hai người phần ngôn bộng ở giáo Trung Quốc lâm kiếm phản đối kế hoạt của tổng thống của quay nào vô đồ đi v業 dây lệ sĩ
Nhằm áp đặt các biển pháp trường pháp lối với các thức thể Trung Quốc bị cho
Là có linh hệ với lúc của quân sự pháp biểu tại học báo mắc kinh
Ông lâm nhìn mấy chúng quốc nhất của anh phản đối với các bạn trường pháp lương phương vì phạm được pháp của tế
Và không được hội đồng bảo an liên hình khúc cho phép
Lông thời kêu vỏ kia nha lập tức sửa trởa xài lâm
Theo ông lâm, mắc kinh đang đồng và trò sây dựng trong việc thuốc đầy cả nỗ lực của mạc bình
Lên quan tờ xung đột u cua nha
Đông thời luôn ruy trì lập trường khác quan
Phản đối việc truyền trị hỏa thương mại và công nghệ
Ông lâm cũng kêu gọi các biển liên quan sử li vất đồng thông qua đối thoại
Thầy vì gây càng thẳng
Tên bố có mắc kinh được lửa ra sau khi ông Zelenski cho đồng muốn ngài nói rằng
Các linh kiện cho Trung Quốc sản xuất đã được phát hiện trong thế hệ mấy bây thông người lại tâm xam mới cùng ngà
Trung Quốc nhiều lần bác bỏ cáu vụ, khẳng lĩnh nước này kiểm soát nghiêm ngà việc xuất khẩu
Các bạn hẳng lĩnh giúp, theo quy định pháp lật